the final episode of hit TV show
Chernobyl as on Monday the series based
on events run in the 1986 nuclear
disaster has revived interest in the
tragedy I'm pleased to report that
situation in Chernobyl is stable
Chernobyl is on fire
and every atom of uranium is like a
bullet
[Music]
some of them will not stop firing for
50,000 years the disaster happened over
30 years ago and is the largest nuclear
accident in history almost 600,000
people were affected and it's thought up
to four thousand will die early as a
result radiation levels in the epicentre
were massively higher than a lethal dose
the disaster led to massive radiation
exposure which was made more widespread
by the wind with Europe and Asia also
affected back to 2008 RT spoke to some
of those involved
yo mr. Bober I think my father
understood very well what danger he was
facing from the very first day when they
flew as a governmental Commission to
Chernobyl they had absolutely no idea
about the situation there because no one
could explain anything when he saw the
state of the fourth block I think he had
already understood everything including
that his life would end with this
situation
[Music]
that'll alleviate such temperature
conditions are difficult the helicopters
they temperature was up to 200 degrees
at different points at a height of 200
meters above the reactor in the burning
heat helicopters hovered over the
exploded reactor engineers threw down
sacks of sand while the pilots struggled
to control the helicopter after one or
two flights like this engineers vomited
on landing the heat along with the
radiation was too much for a human
[Music]
person was but really did we ask you to
confirm orally
there's no time to write papers to
evacuate the whole city of pre PM silly
offer
[Music]
the abandoned city of Pripyat is
situated near the similarly named River
just in 3 kilometers from the Chernobyl
nuclear power plant nowadays it's in the
Chernobyl exclusion zone and supervised
by the authorities of the kiev region
the town also sees excursion tours on a
regular basis
you